Welcome to lesson three. This'll be databases. Databases are
how you actually store all those information that we've
been collecting from users. This is basically the final
piece that'll allow us to build fully functional web applications,
and your homework for this lesson ought to be
actually build the first version of your blog. So. Databases
are actually quite complex. We can spend a lot
of time talking about them. You can actually get a
Ph.D in databases if you want. But, in this lesson, we
have about an hour, so we're going to divide it into
two parts. The first part of this lesson will talk about
SQL and kind of basic database technologies, a lot of things
you'll probably encounter outside of this course. And then, in the
second part of this lesson, we will talk about Google App
Engine's data store which abstracts away a lot of the headaches
of installing a database and getting it setup. It's actually the
reason we decided to use App Engine for this course, it was
the ease of getting started with databases, so let's dive right in.